There's a new study about the effectiveness of the COVID vaccine in children.
Remember that was pushed on children in 2022 is approved by the FDA.
Here it is, protection from COVID-19 vaccination and prior SARS-CoV-2 infection among children
age six months to four years.
So it was authorized in 2022, but there wasn't a lot of real-world data.
In fact, it's still on the effectiveness of these vaccines in the age groups.
It still remains kind of scarce, because there is basically brought it over from the original
clinical trials and said, well, working the adults, let's just move it to children with
the EUA.
Well, now we have 614 children.
This study looked at from six months to four years, the same age group, and what did
they find?
They found this.
There was no difference in risk of infection or symptomatic COVID-19 by vaccination status
alone, regardless of timing of vaccination or manufacturer type.
However, naive participants, that means someone who's never had COVID before, naive participants
vaccinated with Pfizer-BioNTech, were more likely to be infected and experienced symptomatic
COVID-19 compared to naive and unvaccinated participants.
Now, there's a thing that says HR 2.59, that's a hazard ratio.
So what that means is these kids, basically children, were 2.59 times more likely to have an
infection or to experience symptomatic COVID-19 than unvaccinated participants.
This is what it knows, it's 250% more likely to develop a COVID symptom scenario than if
you had nothing at all.
Okay.
And this builds on three other studies.
Now we have four studies showing that not only are the vaccines not effective, they actually
have a higher chance of developing infections or symptoms, and here's an article that really
brilliantly puts it together, four studies established that vaccinated individuals ultimately
face a higher risk of infection compared to those who are not.
And at the same time, you have the CDC still going out on social media, Mandy Cohen, head of
the CDC, goes out on social media and advertises the vaccine.
She writes this, the single best way to risk less severe illness and do more of the things you
enjoy is to get vaccinated against COVID and flu.
Have you made your plan to get vaccinated?
That's what's going on.
That's the experts.
Trust me.
That's it.
Jim Brewer.
Alright, so we have, now let's stand the vaccine conversation, because a lot of these manufacturers,
like Pfizer, like Moderna, they had such a great success with the COVID vaccine that they're
moving on to other vaccines.
Moderna is moving on to the RSV vaccine.
This is a respiratory virus.
It's, it can have complications if you're older, immune suppressed or very, very young children.
And that's where they're testing it in.
They're testing it in kids in Panama five months to seven months old, so extremely small
infants here for this RSV vaccine test.
And there's a problem.
There's what they call a safety signal, a little bit of a roadblock, but don't worry, they'll
get around that roadblock.
That's what the headlines say.
And you can look at this.
Moderna's RSV vaccine run into safety roadblock.
What kind of roadblock?
Well, it's in the study.
There's five cases of severe to very severe lower RSV respiratory tract infections.
Those were reported among 40 of the babies who received the dose, compared to just one in
the placebo group.
What happened to those babies, those infants, five of them, all of them required hospitalization.
One needed mechanical ventilation.
Oh, wait, that was in the study.
I mean, an iron lung?
An iron lung, sure.
Right.
That don't exist anymore?
Cause by a vaccine?
Wow.
That sounds familiar.
Yeah.
I mean, you know what's interesting about this, as a journalist, I'm reading this, and
I look and they had to correct this article, the safety roadblock article, and what do they
say?
Well, apparently the FDA was really looking out for us because they found this.
Well, the author says correction December 11th.
This story has been updated to make it clear that Moderna informed the FDA, the safety findings
that triggered the study pause, not the other way around biospace regrets the error.
So yet another journalist is finding out the FDA is not monitoring these things.
They're relying on the company to go, oops, our problem.
And sometimes company doesn't say, oops, our problem.
But, you know, let's look at the study, the actual study trial, because this is interesting.
They were, they had two interventions, they had two different types of RSV vaccine.
They're both mRNA.
This is where these vaccine industries are going to this new technology, but you see against
a placebo.
So this is a very big story that they use the placebo.
An inert placebo.
Amazing.
I mean, so, so just to be clear here for everyone watching, guess again, all of you reporters.
One of the things that you have said is misinformation is that we say no placebo-based trials were
used in the pre-licensure phase of the 16 vaccines on the childhood, CDC childhood schedule.
And here we're being proven wrong by a brand new trial.
But I mean, what's interesting, Jeffrey, is this proves our point, right?
They've never done.
We've put out a, we have a document that you can look up and, you know, you can see, you
know, whether or not there it is that's on our website.
You can click right there to see it.
It shows all of the safety trials right there on the right.
How long they looked at it?
Did they have a placebo?
None of them.
I think there was one tiny placebo group in an HPV vaccine trial, but they hid the data
on that.
That's a long story.
But essentially, they've never done it.
When they finally do it, when they finally do it on an RSV vaccine program, suddenly they
go, whoa, stop.
Kids are getting sick.
People are being injured.
Now, normally, if you don't have a placebo group, right, because they did show that they had
one severe illness in that placebo group.
So what they would all obviously say without placebo group is kids get sick.
RSV, you know, it happens like it, you know, that would be the natural that, you know, severe
illness needing a respirator needing an iron lung, that would happen whether they got the
vaccine or not.
That's what they argue when there's no comparator.
But when you actually can compare that group and say, nope, sorry, clearly a different result
of the vaccinated compared to the placebo group, now you know why it's so important to New
York Times.
This is why it's important, by the way, was that trial three days long, Jeffrey?
Was it three days, four days, five days?
They found the problems from what I could see around day 85 to 141 in the trial.
So, you know, several months into it that they find these problems.
So look what happens when you go behind beyond three days, New York Times, four days, five
days.
And let me, I want to, I want to do a little thing here, Jeffrey, because I am really tired,
even sat down with a CNN reporter when I was in West Palm a week or so ago.
I said, I'm really tired of you guys just saying, the experts say is your response.
I'm so tired of it.
New York Times, all of you, I'm so tired of you calling that journalism.
That's not journalism.
The experts say, well, Richard Nixon, did you tap the phones over the Watergate Hotel?
No, I did not.
Well, there you have it.
The experts say they didn't do it.
That is what our media has started to do now.
Every single news agency out there has gotten it wrong.
But let me show you how hard this investigation is.
Can I, Jeffrey?
Because I'm really tired of being people saying that, no, they've been studied.
They had placebo tests.
Okay, really?
All right.
Can we give my computer?
Can you make my computer live here?
For everyone reporting out there, I'm just going to show you, you know, what I'd really love
to see.
Okay?
Now, just go to Google, yes, I use Google.
I know some of my people are really upset about that.
FDA License Vaccines, just there it is, the FDA License Vaccines.
It's the first thing that comes up, all right?
Let's click on that.
Vaccines license for use in the United States.
They're all there.
Oh, my God, that was so easy.
Now, let me grab my glasses here.
They're all there.
Let's go down to Hepatitis B vaccine.
This is one of my favorite stories.
There's two of them, obviously, and they're right there.
You can see the package insert.
So this is what you should have been shown if you had informed consent.
This is what the doctor would never hands you.
And frankly, I hear if you do ask for it, then they kick you out of their practice for
wanting information.
But now, on all of these, just go down to 6.1, the clinical trial experience.
This is what they used to approve this for safety.
Can you all read with me in three clinical studies of this Hepatitis B vaccine, 434 doses
of recombivax HB, were administered to 147 healthy infants and children up to 10 years
of age.
I wonder how many of them were infants.
Remember, this is given to day one old babies in America, and they call CPS if you don't
give it up to 10 years of age.
So 147 kids who were monitored for five days.
And there's no placebo group.
So anything that happened in that five days, who knows?
I mean, you just say, well, that was a natural occurrence.
And there's a whole list of side effects I'm not going to get into that they did see.
I'm just asking you, New York Times, Washington Post, all you see it in is a five day safety
review of 147 children between zero and 10 years old, adequate to mandate a vaccine on every
child born in America on their first day of life.
I mean, if it is, then we don't come from the same plan.
Then let's just do it for all of it.
Cancer drug, every cancer drug, all I need is a five day safety trial.
Any loop is drug, a five day safety trial, any exit or any of the things that we see this
long, this white, white even bothers showing the side effects.
You won't have any side effects as long as you only do the study for five days.
And by the way, you can go to that page and read every single vaccine.
And if you can find a placebo trial, call me, I'll stop making this statement.
You won't.
They don't exist.
So this is what we're asking for.
Aaron's series right around the corner, we'll get into it, but let's finish up with you, Jeffrey.
I just had to make that point because journalism really just should not be that hard.